the eu is the world's largest donor of
overseas aid collectively and with
member states individually 51 billion
euros in the next seven years for a
range of development activities on
europe's borders and across the world
the eu insists it's good value for money
and a sound investment but does the
message get out to citizens who may know
nothing and in an era of domestic
recession care less times are bad for a
lot of citizens but then the other side
the table is in the developing world
things are a lot worse that a little bit
of money can save people's lives giving
money and supporting education and other
parts of
cultural development would help reduce
are launching a big campaign in 2015
to raise awareness
the campaign which will cost 15 million
euros is also about showing citizens
that europe doesn't throw its money away
countries need to earn the aid they get
involved in the campaign want policy
changes not just awareness raising all
40 year old policies haven't worked
we've given and given and given and
given and poverty is still there so at
some point you have to say hey these
things are not working what are the new
things that we have to do to eliminate
poverty and create wealth here we are
one new initiative
property rights business registrations
giving value to people's homes so that
they can buy and sell them one key
element woven into many development
programs these days is climate change
mitigation and adaptation
that too will form a part of the
awareness campaign